If the dance scene in Netflix's
"Wednesday" is so awesome,
why are people so upset
about it? Let's take a look.
"Wednesday," is definitely off to a good
start on the streaming giant. The "Addams
Family" spinoff exploded on the platform,
recording the most hours viewed in a week
for an English-language series. Jenna
Ortega is absolutely the standout of
"Wednesday," as everyone has been praising
her performance. Unfortunately for her though,
newly-surfaced information has her
trending online for all the wrong reasons.
"They want answers, and so do I!"
"I would lead the inquisition, but I
left my thumb screws and rack at home."
During a recent interview with NME, the
actress unintentionally threw herself under
the bus. As the interview dives deeper
into the show, Wednesday's dance number,
found in Episode 4, "Woe What a Night," became
the topic of conversation. Ortega revealed:
The interviewer was confused by the statement,
which led Ortega to more or less double down
on it. She reflected on waking up with body
aches and a sore throat and still went to
set and filmed the scene, receiving medicine
in between takes. She kept filming until her
test results came back positive. MGM later
told the outlet that the studio implemented
strict COVID protocols after the tests confirmed
Ortega had COVID, but fans weren't having it.
While NME released the interview nearly
a month ago, the information surrounding
Ortega's COVID diagnosis recently took
off on social media. It doesn't help the
situation that the interview formatted the
story in a way that showed Ortega's strength
in pushing through the performance while
battling the illness. Regardless of intent,
fans didn't see it that way at
all. One twitter user stated:
Many agreed with the user's sentiment,
echoing their disappointment for Ortega,
director Tim Burton, and Netflix
for putting more importance on
the scene than the lives of the
cast and crew. Another user added:
Most likely, this is much bigger than Ortega.
Another Twitter user put into question
the COVID protocols on set. Since Ortega
woke up with symptoms, any protocols that
were actually in place should have kept
her isolated until the test results returned.
And another user brought things full circle,
saying that these events are the
result of American culture that
glorifies someone risking their life
and the lives of others for their job.
Some Twitter users came to Ortega's defense,
saying that other people are at fault for
not having the actress isolate while she
waited for her results. One user wrote:
Other users took it upon themselves to
blame Netflix. No one can be sure what
went on behind the scenes, but there was
plenty of theorizing in the comments. Some
suggested it was just routine testing
and it happened to come out positive.
These events aren't even the first time that the
production of "Wednesday" came under fire. Last
week, fans took to social media to criticize
the show's portrayal of Black characters.
"Where has she hithered?"
"You mean Wednesday Addams? Knowing her
she's hithered somewhere she shan't be."
As the director of the first four episodes, Burton
was the target of criticism for using the show's
black characters as the main antagonists,
with many fans claiming it was a racist move.